kaneki knows he's about to be brutally  murdered when suddenly his one eye turns  into the eye of a horrifying ghoul this  stuns the crowd as they realize just how  rare of a species kaneki truly is purple  hair guy in the distance sees this and  gets a terrifying idea he suddenly stops  the game and tells kaneki that this was  all one big joke and lets kaneki go free  for now the next morning kaneki finds  out that toka has gotten sick from  eating too much of her human friend's  food but she doesn't realize that her  niceness will cost her tonight kaneki  then heads out into town and runs into  glasses guy getting beat up he saves him  and dumps him off at his apartment where  he meets his girlfriend and she's human  this girl says that glasses guy needs  human flesh to heal but having none  there kaneki runs back to the coffee  shop to get some and that was his  biggest mistake